ma va ma non vi impari cat e la maturità
e la passeggiata ve lo assicuro anzi se
vi posso dare un consiglio
godetevi ogni singolo istante perché è
un periodo meraviglioso
ve lo ricorderete per tutta la vita è
certo dicono tutti che una passeggiata
soltanto perché l'hanno già fatto a o ri
mortacci vostra
calcolando i crediti accumulati se
all'età le facce scena muta anni
promuovono le stesse ma tu conosci
qualcuno che conosce commissari esterni
settant'anni fa paura sento non fa
cultura
vabbè tanto dopo gli scritti ci sono
ancora dei giorni ma studiato ragazzi
facciamo un gruppo studio e se mi viene
un attacco di panico e vengono avanti a
tutti e crollo e rotolo per terra che
figura ci faccio matura non si fa paura
yeah e se mi dimentico tutto ma qualcuno
mi deve spiegare come faccia ridurrà un
anno intero in sette giorni già
impossibile e domani studio una materia
e al giorno così non mi stresso e arrivo
preparatissima il giorno dell'esame e se
non solo argomento della busta no scusa
maria ma la busta non era una sola so
perché io ne vedo tre sono un po confusa
anche se mi metto a studiare il problema
che sto antipatica tutti i prof
nel boccia non è sicura ma manca una
settimana la maturità io non ho ancora
capito come funzionalità morale ma che
me frega io mi presento a e basta un po
ti ho detto che mi metto a studiare dopo
dopo sai che pur di dopo dopo ma si
tanto è una formalità
non è mica difficile come esame o ma se
non riesco a trovare collegamenti se non
capita quella giusta scena muta e cambio
busta ma secondo tino se riesci a gubbio
sì dico proprio te mi ha detto il prof
di filosofia che se non ti iscrivi al
canale di marina ti bocciano devi farlo
assolutamente io l'ho per fatto e clicca
anche sulla campanella vicino tassa
d'iscrizione
mi raccomando incrociamo le dita
chi mano cioè ce l'hanno fatta a tutti
ce la faremo anche noi è un po di
fortuna
lo santo cioè boccione sicuro sicuro a
un certo languorino e vado a fare un bel
bicchierone di magnesio non riuscirò mai
a studiare tutto mai no maria ti prego
cioè chiudi la busta ma che stiamo
scherzando
cioè io dovrei studiato testa rom ma
figure vabbè dai questo nome potrà mai
chiedere cioè non abbiamo neanche fatto
prof
quando arriva a 70 anni fermi pure ma
sai che me frega mi facevo c'era e basta
oddio vuoto non mi ricordo più nulla
cercavo
non mi ricordo niente di quello che ho
studiato oggi niente
amo non posso studiare cioè prima devo
guardare il nuovo video di marina ovvio
che poi s'è capito perché hanno cambiato
la maturità ok amo quindi questa cosa
non la studio perché non la chiede come
studiano allo stesso non si sa mai
tra follia e innocenza mi basta la
sufficienza che anche oggi hanno
studiato nulla grazia instagram
tanto ormai quello che so se allora io
deciso sentirmi bene io fingo di aver
già febbre all'orale così faccio pietà
alla commissione e promuovono non
possono bocciarmi ci sono malata esame
di fuoco comincia la danza da mio 60 e
vado in vacanza o vorrei proprio sapere
che lo stronzo che ha inventato sa
buffonata della maturità amore ufficiale
siamo nella merda
qui si sboccia non si boccia ma come
fate aver paura della prima prova è un
tema d'italiano facilissimo ave maria
piena di grazia il signore con te ti
prego mi bastano 60 ambarabà ciccì coccò
quale gusta sceglierà boss vogliono
bronzo ma questo argomento quando cavolo
abbiamo fatto maschi tante prost e
aiuteranno no o da domani inizia a
studiare promesso è promesso ma perché
ti preoccupi tanto se hai studiato
durante tutto l'anno non è nulla da
temere sarà facilissimo
siamo appena finisco iri brucia tutti i
libici avrebbe faccio un mega sala
aiutiamoci anche oggi si sta domani
quindi cinemino dai come sto
amo l'ansia online se non mi ricordo
niente che studio che non ricordo più
non ricordo che ho l'ansia più paura di
essere bocciato più l'ansia più la cia
medico ma chi c'era ha datto varie di
iscriversi al liceo cioè nel senso
potevamo andare a zappare la terra no ma
stai tranquilla non ti devi preoccupare
perché gli iscritti si può copiare
io ti farò copiare
[Musica]